[موسيقى]
هو النهائي الثالث الذي يجمع منتخبين
عربيين بعد نسختي 96
و2007 المنتخب القطري يتوق للاحتفاظ
باللقب القاري ليصبح خامس منتخب يحقق ذلك
الانجاز العنابي تخلص من عقبه المنتخب
الايراني بثلاثه اهداف مقابل هدفين في نصف
النهائي
كل طرف يرغب في تحقيق الفوز نحن نعرف ان
العلاقات بين البلدين قويه جدا لكننا في
النهايه سننافس بقوه في هذه المباراه
واجهنا عقبات من قبل لم تكن رحله سهله
الان نحن هنا لكننا لم نحقق الانجاز
بعد اما المنتخب الاردني مفاجاه البطوله
الساره فتاه للمباراه النهائيه للمره
الاولى في تاريخه قطع النشامه بطاقه
العبور للنهائي بعد الانتصار كوريا
الجنوبيه بهدفين دون مقابل في نصف النهائي
المدرب حسين عموته اكد ان المباراه بمثابه
مواجهه عائليه ولذلك تمنى ان يرتقي
النهائي لتشريف الكره العربيه والاسيويه
قبل النهائيه يعني صراحه لا تحتاج يعني ان
تقدم ولا يعني ان نتكلم على الرغبه رغبه
الفريقين
يعني البصم على انجاز
ولقب ممكن يكون تاريخي طبعا نحن نستعد
يعني بشكل يعني عادي يعني بدون ما يعني
نزيد يعني من
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
الضغط